el tema de ese rebelde porque eso es
parte de tener un poco de actitud es
parte también como de romper esquemas es
algo que a mí siempre me ha gustado y
que recientemente estábamos hablando que
atrás y es que bueno que puedas rodearte
de personas que aceptan que vos sos una
persona que rompe esquemas entonces
vamos a hablar de estos 10 mandamientos
que me interesa que ustedes aprendan a
hacer rebeldes con causa o por lo menos
a rebelarse en ciertos aspectos de su
vida y el primer mandamiento es
rebelarse hacer lo que vos no querés
pero con un motivo racional porque este
tema de la rebeldía generalmente se
trata como me rebelo de mis papás no en
mi casa los 18 y que uno piensa que lo
que soy se puede ir pero no me hacía los
27 y no por rebeldes sino porque ya
estaba vieja y había que irse y a los 27
es igual no te estás casando tennessee
vasco qué onda que ahora ve a este toca
entonces no fue por rebelde que me fui a
mi casa sino porque ya uno tiene que
emprender ese viaje solito entonces
enfrente y revelarte hacer lo que no
quieres para mí era punto número uno me
rebelé a una beca en el colegio yo era
esa mezcla extraña entre verdad pero que
nunca tenía buena conducta entonces pero
la buena conducta o la mala conducta no
te hace no graduarte
entonces me ganó una beca para estudiar
en una universidad de prestigio economía
y yo me quedé como
porque no me dejan escoger una carrera
no voy a estudiar economía pero para mi
papá que es un máster en administración
y esas cosas para que leer a alguien va
a usar todos los libros que yo compre
y yo era como esos libros aburridos
jamás le dije papi si me la gané que
archivó pero no la quiero no quiero
estudiar esto y pasamos a esa transición
en la que le dije sabe que si no
entonces yo voy a ver cómo hago para
estudiar la carrera que yo quiera
y fue así como yo me metí en diseño yo
quería estudiar diseño de modas pero en
ese momento no existía porque aunque no
lo crean ya estoy vieja los 32 años
recién cumplidos esté bueno para los que
no se sienten así pues qué bien pero yo
me siento como que hace 10 años no
existía hace 10 años me gradué y no
existía la carrera entonces dije me meto
en gráfico y iphone donde yo empecé
revelando me contra esa beca luego me
rebelé a ser una empleada cuando yo
empecé a la universidad del diseño para
los que no saben es una carrera cara
porque tenéis que gastar muchos
materiales y ahora cada semana para
piqué para pagar unas fotos para picar
unos colores para unos mongol porque no
te compra yo team que ese primer color
nunca me compro lo primer color y nos
pedían una pega especial divina que el
llevaba una resistol y medicina es lo
mismo no
yo vivía frustrada porque mi papá era de
esos que en el colegio nos compraba el
set de cuadernos del quijote y nos
llevaba papel periódico ilustre nos
decía forren los lindos
y yo dije no voy a pasar a la
universidad en esta lid ya me tengo que
hacer algo por mí
y entonces entré a trabajar en un call
center por cuatro años y se imagina lo
que es para una niña yo entré de 16 a la
universidad
y a los 18 entra el call center que no
puede trabajar desde antes pero justo a
los 18 entré al call center y esa fue mi
primera experiencia de trabajo y ahí
pasé cuatro años de los cuales cuando
iba a terminar el nivel ya terminé la
universidad nos dijeron bueno para
grabar sí que pagar un seminario que
cuesta mil dólares más la grabación y
ella quería una fiesta digna porque le
había costado la carrera cuando éste
pagar la carrera como quiera celebrar de
verdad no sé si hice cálculos
y mención de mi jefe y quiero que me
despida
estás loca
porque es que un en vivo entonces yo
había hecho cálculos de lo que te daban
cuando te despiden
y me alcanzaba hasta para una laptop y
le compré también mamá una máquina con
la que se plancha así de vapor que la
odio porque dijo que era un ser
doméstico pero me alcanzaba su sitio
leía mi jefe despidan porque sabe que yo
igual me voy a ir mejor le ayuda a una
mujer que se quiere graduar y celebrar
en grande
y él me dijo de todas maneras esta es lo
que te vas a querer ir así que no puedo
hacer nada por retener y me da mi cheque
y para la única loca como recurso humano
así como ya gracia
voy con mi cheque y no tengo fotos por
todo me rebelé yo no quería ser
empleadas entonces dije bueno voy a
guardar de aquí un poquito para poder
poner mi negocio yo quería de diseño
obviamente
en ese momento antes de empezar en el
diseño de más que todo lo que estoy
haciendo en este momento que ya les voy
a contar de modas yo todavía seguía en
la parte de gráfico yo todavía decía que
voy a hacer necesito ponerme mi propio
negocio y al revelar me ser empleada lo
que se me ocurrió fue poner mi propia
empresa y decir soy una agencia de
diseño grande
con un portafolio diverso en el que solo
tenía las planas de teoría del color
dibujos horribles que me quedaban pero
gracias a dios tenía una pasantía que yo
había hecho y este es mi punto número 2
valorar las oportunidades tomarlas sin
miedo recuerdo que se me presenta hacer
una pasantía la oportunidad de una
pasantía con una marca super grande a
nivel de latinoamérica pero una jefa que
no les puede explicar cómo era yo la
puedo escribir como negrera pero a la
vez
fabulosa porque fue la única que le dio
la oportunidad dio valor a la gente que
me da una oportunidad así como me ven
porque generalmente aquí estamos en un
país de estereotipos en el que te ven
así es como y están locas no no creo que
algo bueno por su vida sea drogado
para nada
y me encantaría estar fruta pero me
duele entonces son mis ojos chiquitos y
ando como duele mucho no hay muchos
estereotipos y creyó en mí me dio la
oportunidad y me dijo pero la pasantía
de un año sin pagar te
como brand manager me dije pero como el
nombre si voy al libro divino
yo dije
démosle una oportunidad y yo puedo andar
dice soy brand manager aunque ben spies
y se imaginan a esta altura decirle al y
el sol brand manager para la marca sea
eso es como wow y dije este es el
momento para aprovechar que en mi
portafolio salga de las planas de teoría
del color y tener algo más
esa fue la oportunidad que yo decidí
tomar para poder poner mi negocio de
diseño
y la siguiente oportunidad grande que
tuve que tomar fue momento en el que
decidimos empezar en el diseño de modas
poner esta tienda de ropa masculina
y de repente alguien nos escribió en un
productor de modas y dijo quiero ver lo
que vamos a hacer mándame todos tus
bocetos y ella no sabía aceptar
y quiero ver tu colección
pero la oportunidad la tomé y dije aquí
tengo que entrar para meterme en la moda
aunque yo no sepa nada de moda porque
eso es una oportunidad y a veces
nosotros les dejamos pasar inclusive en
la parte del networking el networking
para mí es una cosa sumamente importante
y en todo qué evento que ando parezco
repartidora de semáforo con la tarjeta
de presentación citado a mí todos mi
equipaje porque siempre sirve hacer
networking siempre hay alguien que te
pueda una oportunidad
número 3 entonces
eso me lleva al mantener siempre los
pies en la tierra porque los títulos y
conocimientos no te hacen más que nadie
y eso lo aprendí muy bien cuando yo
empecé la universidad que les conté que
no había diseño de modas mi papá mejor
sabes que te va a apoyar en algo te voy
a meter a una academia costura porque
los oficios siempre sirven
academia costura salió imaginada como en
paso vamos a hacer una universidad de
moda bueno pero veamos que hay en el
salvador vea y entonces me dijo si te
voy a llevar ya te pague una y vamos a
ir y me compró una máquina linda divina
para ir a mi clase porque mi papi era de
los que el primer día clase uno tiene
que ir con sus útiles completos
ella iba con su útiles
parecía la de legally blonde solo me
faltaba el chihuahua k mi máquina bella
porque además se le cambia esta carátula
y entró y era una academia en el centro
de san salvador
donde estaba lleno de mujeres que para
viaje hacer al oficio y su carrera de
vida
y entro yo me pagó
se imagina en el primer día hay olas y
vengo a estudiar
modas
ok pase siéntese bienvenida yo así y
todas con sus máquinas saben cómo me
sentí
como frijoles con caviar o sea así raro
era feo porque es cuando de verdad sabes
que no tienes los pies en la tierra
y de repente estas mujeres eran como
miren que se siente ir a la universidad
millicom a la universidad y que haya la
universidad en ese momento o todo ese
tiempo que yo estuve en la academia
costura aprendiendo la base de
fue donde yo más aprendí a valorar mis
estudios a valorar que no todos podemos
tener la oportunidad de estudiar y
entonces esto me lleva
a ser un diente multiplicador porque
estábamos rodeadas de mujeres que
pensaban yo solo quiero hacer la
costurera que haga las cortinas los
arreglitos en mi colonia yo siempre
decía piense más allá piense más allá
porque puede hacer algo más con lo que
está aprendiendo y para mí ser un ente
multiplicador es influenciar a otros de
forma positiva y es algo que los que me
sigan en los que me conozcan van a ver
que yo siempre trato de hacer si alguien
me dijo mira vos yo soy influencia dora
ok si soy micro influenciado ahora que
lo voy a hacer de la forma positiva que
pueda porque no se ve el influenciar que
te manda una carterita
hasta en moda no de vez en cuando toca
pero qué mal estás haciendo para
influenciar a los demás y en todo
seminario que puedo capacitación si
puedo dar clases lo hago porque pienso
que todos tenemos que compartir los
conocimientos que vamos adquiriendo
porque de eso se trata la vida siempre
hay alguien que te enseña algo y vos
deberías de tratar de enseñarle a otro
por ende
número 5
es cuestionarte todo porque debo hacer
las cosas así para quien me va a servir
yo soy la persona de las más cercas que
se van a conocer en la vida si alguien
me dice al ver cómo y por qué pero para
qué o por qué no lo voy a hacer porque
una mujer no se va a meter a diseñar
para hombres y las mujeres tener un
mejor gusto
y si no vean a todas las mujeres cuando
no conocen mis yo quisiera que así se
vieran bien
y yo yo sé
mire lléveme lo yo voy a tratar de
verdad no le prometo nada pero lo voy a
intentar y lo lleva con la camisa de
juego de poli el para tala
hay casos difíciles pero se trata
entonces porque no me voy a meter a
diseñar para hombres por supuesto que lo
voy a hacer cuestiones de todo si debe o
no debe hacer las cosas número 6
perdón salir de tu zona de confort
la comodidad nunca te va a permitir
avanzar es el momento en el que a mí me
pasó cuando yo dije tengo un 9 años ya
con diseño diseño marca se enfoque más
en estrategias para redes sociales
manejar en las redes a los clientes pero
que estoy haciendo con mi vida de verdad
estoy haciendo todo lo que él me gusta
si me gusta el diseño vivo de eso pero
también ahora vivo de diseñar ropa para
hombres porque porque me salí de mi zona
de confort y cuanto aquí estamos en esa
zona de aquí tengo mi salario que me
alcanza para esto para lo otro pero no
queremos reventar al charco de emprender
o de cambiarte de trabajo o por lo menos
hacer lo que de verdad te gusta eso es
salir de tu zona de confort
siguiente número 7 es seguir las líneas
aunque no siempre van a ser rectas pero
yo digo las curvas también son chivas
miren hay tantas cosas que no han pasado
en este camino como el hecho de que
ningún banco nos quiso apoyar porque era
como que lo que quieren hacer o sea es
una sastrería no miren es una sastre así
como que usted llega y pide el traje
como con las no es otro estilo y killen
senama tenemos
porque eso pasa pues llegan a pedir un
préstamo para un carro y te lo dan en
dos patadas pero pedí para un negocio y
número daba y mi hermano y yo estábamos
frustrando unos y de repente fue como
sabes que cambiamos el giro al negocio y
en lugar de tener el montón de trajes
mejor hagamos lo que podemos con lo que
tenemos
hagamos a la medida que la gente venga
personalice y convirtamos lo es una
experiencia porque las líneas están pero
de nosotros depende como las vamos a
agarrar
número 8 este de mis favoritas convertir
todo en un reto personal de verdad para
mí todo un reto les voy a contar de cómo
me tocó aprender abocetar porque cuando
el productor me pidió mi colección
yo esto era lo que hacía
porque como ya no sabe dibujar
me acuerdo que contratamos al sastre y
yo y como él explicó como quiero porque
yo no estudiado modas
obviamente me tocó empaparme de todos
los cortes o sea yo de verdad hombre que
veo y es como hay los hombros las
hombreras le quedan mal ahí el corte si
les puedo decir de todos los que han
pasado que el cómo están sus tras mentir
pero
y me lo pueden llevar se las arregla
pero me toco empaparme de eso para que
el hombre que llegue yo le diga a usted
le favorece este tipo de corte ese tipo
de solapas con nuestros botones con este
tipo de tela
pero entonces mire yo y dije cómo no les
explicará sastre voy a hacer esto
agarrar una revista y sobre esa dibujaba
y cuando ya le sacaba del papel vegetal
y él veía el boceto ese mes a quien no
puede dibujar
y yo mire yo sé que la solapa no me
quedó bien que parece un cuello de mujer
pero no en las y gusta imaginarlo como
de verdad es entonces mi reto era
cambiar eso y en el siguiente año que
volví a presentar otra colección en otra
pasarela también mi forma de voz estar y
evolucione un poquito
saben lo difícil que es para un
diseñador gráfico y ser es los de en
serio es difícil excepto para los que sí
saben ilustrar
y yo dije no en un cuaderno de cuadritos
marcar mejor ya le ponía los pedazos de
tela que yo quería y comillas los harvey
que los amos empecé pero en la siguiente
colección dije no necesita evolucionar
porque eso todavía se ve muy propio y de
verdad todavía lo es calcada entonces
dije mejor como éste
pero todo ya no iba al bbva
me voy a poner en la computadora voy a
armar una plantilla y lo voy a hacer
bien que hasta el sastre se quedó como
evolución no totalmente ser una
plantilla ya era un maniquí que parecía
un hombre de verdad donde yo diseñaba y
le ponía los pedacitos de tela y él ha
visto esa constante ha sido como
muy bien pero dígame solo diseñadora
porque me estoy rebuscando por estar
entre el gráfico y la moda saben y mi
siguiente reto personal fue que viene
una amiga que tiene una academia de
danza y me dice voy a hacer un tributo a
disney y no hay nadie más quiero me
imaginé nur sula como vos
perdón entonces
regresamos la anterior
ahí está
es una pena
puedes perderla entera no hay nadie que
se me imaginé en úrsula como vos y
entonces vienen y me dicen necesitamos
que hagan este papel pero es una
academia de ballet sabes que nunca ha
hecho ballet en mi vida tengo 32 años
pero te voy a enseñar cómo enseñar
rápido y tú mirarse a dos meses
intensivos y llego yo y un montón de
niñas que las que le llegaban aquí
y yo
para mí yo miras a vela úrsula boza una
gran falta entonces esos grandes brincos
y no solo
y resuelve voy a hacer una sola
y voy a bailar un poquito de ballet pero
no sé imaginé que con un tutú porque no
no me va pero fue proyecto que te quiero
decir con esto todo en la vida es un
reto personal pero eso nos lleva al
penúltimo punto que es pensar fuera de
la caja
casey ya supere todos estos retos ahora
pienso fuera de la caja porque los locos
los que pensamos diferente somos los que
podemos cambiar el mundo nosotros somos
pocos en el taller pero siempre nosotros
estamos enfocados en y qué podemos hacer
de la gente que es una empresa local que
nosotros somos los que fabricamos tus
cosas que estamos creciendo juntos como
ustedes crean en el país crean en que
somos un país que de verdad tenemos
boada que tenemos talento que hay buenos
diseñadores acá pensar fuera de la caja
significa que hagas cosas que no estás
acostumbrado a hacer
para finalmente mantenerte en una
constante evolución porque en este
momento mi hermano y yo estamos
revolucionando la sastrería y la hemos
convertido en una experiencia para que
el hombre que nunca sabe lo que quiere
en trajes
porque lo demás son muy decididos
llegue y diga esto quiero con este corte
con este cuello con estos botones y se
va con una experiencia diferente porque
hay un dicho que dice que la única
manera de evolucionar es que usted haga
siempre las cosas de forma diferente así
que muchísimas gracias
[Aplausos]